تصاعدت وثيره الضغط على النظام السوري مع
بدء موجه عقوبات اقتصاديه ودبلوماسيه
عربيه وتركيه وربما قريبه امريكيه ومع ان
تغييرات ل مدى فاعليه هذا الخيار وتباين
الا انه يفرح تساؤلين حول ما اذا كان يمثل
الفرصه الاخيره لنظام دمشق كي يتفادى
تدخلا اجنبيا مستقبلا
ام
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين
اولا ما مدى فعاليه العقوبات المفروضه على
نظام دمشق وقدرتها على تحقيق الغايه منها
ثم هل فشل هذا الخيار يقرب سوريا تلقائيا
من خيار التدخل الاجنبي المثير للانتخاب
اذا دائره العقوبات
على نظام الاسد تكاد تطبق عليه من كافه
الاتجاهات الاموال العربيه ستتوقف عن
الجريان في شريان اقتصاد النظام ونفقه
المتدفق الى اوروبا سينقطع غسيل حركه
التجاره التركيه
سيف العقوبات هو خيار المرحله بعد ما اسم
عاصمه دمشق اذ انها واغمضت عيونها عن كل
المخارج التي فتحت امامها لكن ماذا لو
اقفلت دمشق هذه النافذه ان يفتح الباب
تلقائيا امام خيار الضروره خيار التدخل
الاجنبي الذي لطالما حرص الجميع على الناي
ان هو تجميد سوريا مخاطر تدويل ثورتها
الساعيه لنظام ديمقراطي
يطلق الحريات ويرفع القمه ويؤثر دوله
حديثه
لم تكن الا
ونحاول الولوج منها حرصا على العمل العربي
المشترك
لكنهم بالامس
بالقرار الذي اتخذوه
اغلقوا هذه النوع من اغلق النوافذ على من
هل هي الجامعه العربيه التي فعلت ذلك بفرض
عقوبات اقتصاديه على دمشق ان نظام الرئيس
بشار الاسد الذي فوت المهله والفرصه
العربيه الواحده تلو الاخرى والتي كان
اخرها المبادره العربيه لايجاد حلول لما
تشهده سوريا من اعمال عنف وقتل متواصله
ولانه اضع الفرص التي قدمت اليه قالت
تركيا اليوم على لسان وزير خارجيتها ان
النظام السوري وصل الى نهايه الطريق وب
كلام اوضح انضمت انقره الى قائمه اغلبيه
الدول العربيه عبر اعلانها رزمه العقوبات
على النظام السوري تشمل تجميل اصوله في
تركيا ووقف التعامل مع المصرف المركزي
اضافه الى فرض حظر السفر على كبار مسؤوليه
وكان تصريحات الوزير التركي سبقها تصريح ل
وزير الاقتصاد والتجاره اللبناني اعلن فيه
ان لبنان ملتزم ب تنفيذ العقوبات على
سوريا رغم عدم تصويته عليها تاتي هذه
التحركات عشيه اجتماع وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسيل للمصادقه على
حزمه جديده مشدده من العقوبات النفطيه
والماليه تشمل بحسب مصادر اوروبيه منع
تصدير معدات للقطاع الغاز والنفط واستهداف
مصادر تمويل الحكومه السوريه وكان الخناق
بات يضيق اكثر فاكثر على نظام دمشق عربيا
واقليميا وهو ما اعتبره المعلم حربا
اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه على بلاده من دون ان
يمنع ذلك بعض المسؤولين السوريين من
التاكيد ان دمشق يمكنها من خلال الاكتفاء
الذاتي تجاوز سيف العقوبات وفي ظل هذه
المعطيات العربيه والدوليه التي تشير الى
ان النظام السوري وضع نفسه في موقف صعب
يبقى السؤال الابرز هل يتلقف نظام خيار
الحل العربي ويحول بذلك دون تحقق نبوه ان
رياح التدويل قد تهب على سوريا في القريب
العاجل
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاردني السابق ورئيس
مركز البسيطه للدراسات الدكتور جواد
العناني
وينضم الينا من الطبول الدكتور محمد
العادل مدير المعهد التركيه العربي
للدراسات نرحب بضيفنا من اسطنبول من عمان
ابدا معك من عمان الدكتور جواد العناني
نتحدث عن خيار
العقوبات اليوم على القمه العربيه
والعقوبات التركيه على سوريا كي
نفهم مدى
فعاليه هذه العقوبات يجب بالتاكيد ان نفهم
في البدايه اليه غير الاقتصاد السوري
الواقع ال التجاري العربي السوري هل لك ان
تعطينا لمحه مختصره عنها دكتور الجمعه
اه اعتقد بان العقوبات قد قصد منها ان
توجه ضد النظام اكثر مما قصد منها ان تكون
موجهه الى الشعب السوري وقد كان هنالك حرص
واضح على الفصل بين الاثنين ولكننا في
تطبيق العمل الواقع اه لا اعتقد ان هذا
الفصل سيكون دقيقا او ممكن التطبيق فمثلا
اه قيل بان اه اه سيمنع الكبار المسؤولين
من السفر اه اه ستتخذ اه هنالك اه اه
اغلاق الحسابات في المصارف اه كذلك الحال
اه توقف عمليات البنك التجاري والبنك
المركزي السوري
نعم تجميد الاستثمارات العربيه في سوريا
نريد ان نعرف حجم الاستثمارات او خارقه
الاستثمارات العربيه في سوريا
اه الحقيقه ان خارطه الاستثمارات العربيه
في سوريا قد بدات تنمو في الاونه الاخيره
بشكل ملحوظ خاصه وان سوريا كانت قد بدات
تتخذ اجراءات افتتاحيه في اخر ست سبع
سنوات مما جذب اليه كثيرا من الاستثمارات
في مجالات السياحه مجالات الاعمار اه كذلك
في مجال الجامعات في مجال اه ال ال ال ال
ال اه سيتي وال وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
وكذلك في مجال اه في مجال الصناعي اه
واعتقد بان حجم الاستثمارات العربيه
الخليجيه وغير الخليجيه اه في سوريا ربما
اه كانت قد وصلت بحدود اطناش الى ثلاثه
عشر مليار دولار اه هذه استثمارات كبيره
لا باس بها حتى ان الاردن دوله لها
استثمارات موجوده في سوريا وفي الجامعات
هناك اكثر من جراء ساهم فيها الاردنيون
كذلك اه فتحت البنوك الاردنيه
فروعا لها في
سوريا اه ومن هنا حتى من دوله جاره
كالاردن اه هنالك استثمارات محاوله
مليون دولار من دوله ثاره اخرى هي تركيا
والسؤال للدكتور محمد العادل هذه العقوبات
التي تشمل المبادلات التجاريه
وايضا المعاملات المصرفيه نريد ان نعرف ما
حجم هذه المبادرات والمعاملات بين تركيا
وسوريا
منذ ان وقعت تركيا اه اتفاقيه اه اه يعني
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع تركيا مع سوريا
عفوا اه وبدات المصالحه مصالحه تركيا مع
محيطها العربي والاسلامي وبدات ها مع
سوريا توجهت يعني ال او نشطت حركه التجاره
بين البلدين
سواء الحركه البينيه لاسيما بعد الغاء
التاشيرات فنشرت حركه ال حركه التجاره
الحدوديه بالاضافه الى نشاط السياحه
وبالتالي يقدر هنا حجم التبادل التجاري
يناهز الثلاثه مليار دولار يعني بين
البلدين بالاضافه الى يعني ما ان اه
عائدات السياحه للطرفين
وهناك ايضا مشروعات تمويليه يقوم بتمويلها
بنك اه اه مصارف حكوميه تركيه في داخل
سوريا بالاضافه الى ان هناك ارصده سوريا
يقال لعدد من المسؤولين وربما للحكومه
السوريه نفسها في البنوك التركيه وبالتالي
انا ارى ان هذه الحزمه من العقل العقوبات
اعتقد بلا شك ستكون لها انعكاسات كبيره
على النظام السوري ولكن بلا
الشعب السوري اه كيف يمكن ان تكون هذه
العقوبات قد صممت
بالطريقه التي لا يمكن ان تؤدي او تضر بها
الشعب السوري
يعني اعتقد بان يعني هذا ال القول المبالغ
فيه يعني انا ارى بان ال اه هذه الجمله من
العقوبات ستؤثر بشكل او باخر يعني على
الشعب السوري حيث حينما نتحدث عن وقف
العمل مع البنك المركزي السوري ومع عدد من
المصارف السوريه معنى ذلك ان التجاره
البينيه ايضا ستتاثر وان عدد كبير من
التجار السوريين الذين لديهم معاملات
مباشره و يوميه مع السوق التركي اعتقلت
السوق وهذا سينعكس
بشكل او باخر على حياه المواطن السوري ولو
بشكل تدريجي لكن يعني تركيا تدرك هذا
الامر وترى بان هذه الخطوه الاولى في هذه
العقوبات على الاقل يعني لمزيد من الضغط
واحكام الضغط على النظام السوري واجباره
على الانصياع الانصياع
للنداءات الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه
والانصياع ايضا بدرجه اولى الى الشارع
السوري
لكن هل استنفذت
تركيا كل هذه العقوبات انها ستاتي بشكل
تدريجي تستكمل في مرحله اه اللاحقه هامش
او ثامنها
اه في تقديري ان هذه ال مجرد مقدمه يعني
اه هذه اه حزمه من العقوبات الاقتصاديه
والماليه اه ل ل ل ل ل للضغط على النظام
سوى ايضا ل اه التفاعل مع القرارات
العربيه وقرارات اوروبيه اخرى وربما ايضا
ان ننتظر قرارات خلال اليومين القادمين من
الاتحاد الاوروبي اه قد اه يعني اه اه
يلجا النظام السوري الى لهجه جديده مختلفه
تماما يعني يحاول يعني اه اخراج نفسه من
هذه القبضه واذا اصر فان تركيا في تقدير
ستتجه الى احكام العزله وربما التوجه بشكل
رسمي للاحتفال الاعتراف
بالمجلس الوطني السوري وبالتالي يعني
تجريد النظام السوري تدريجيا من شرعيته
وهذا ينسجم ايضا مع توجهات بعض الدول
العربيه ومع اطراف اوروبيه اخرى
يعني هذا السؤال مهم سنتوقف عنده اه اه اه
لمده اطول ربما من بقيه المحاور من الذي
سيحضر اكثر النظام امن الشعب كان يتحدث
الان الدكتور محمد العادل عن تصميم
العقوبات بالشكل يؤدي النظام اكثر ولكن ما
نشاهده الان على الارض ان هناك الى سوريا
كثيره مثلا تضررت من موضوع قطع الكهرباء
بسبب كيف تركيا عن تزويد سوريا بالتيار
الكهربائي اكيد السوق السوداء تنتعش اكثر
ست غلو الاسعار في النهايه ربما الشاب
سيدفع ثمن هذه العقوبات اليس كذلك
قطعا الشعب السوري في الظروف الحاليه هو
يدفع حاليا يدفع اه ولكن قطع العقوبات
الاقتصاديه
اذا نجحت في تحقيق اهدافها سوف تؤدي في
نهايه الامر ليس فقط الى الغلاء والى
السوق السوداء وانما ايضا سيدفع الحكومه
السوريه الى التعامل بالنقد وليس مثلا عن
فتره اعتمادات او استخدامات مصرفيه واذا
بدات استخدام النقد فان هذا سيعرض للعمل
مع وسطاء سيجدون في هذا فرصه ثمينه جدا
لذلك سينشا مضاربه على العمله السوريه
نفسها وسيجد كل واحد سوري نفسه اه اه يبحث
عن عمله اجنبيه او ان صعبه عن طريق
استبدالها بما لديه من ليرات سوريه ولهذا
فان اول شيء سيحصل وان الليره السوريه سوف
تكون معارضه لمزيد من التراجع والهبوط
نعم لاننا نعتقد بانه يجب على اه الاخوه
في سوريا اه اه المسؤولين في القطاع الخاص
اه كذلك ان يدركوا بان نتيجه هذه العقوبات
الاقتصاديه هي في الواقع ستؤدي الى هبوط
العمله السوريه والى حصول اه غلاء كبير
جدا وازدياد السوق السوداء اه قطعا هذه
كلها في نهايه الامر ستؤثر تاثيرا مباشرا
على فئه الشعب وبخاصه على الفئات صاحبه
الدخول الثابته اه والافكار يعني وهذا
ربما ربما يكون في صالح من يضع هذه
العقوبات الاقتصاديه
سيؤدي الى زياده
غضب الناس اه مما يجري وستحصل هنالك معركه
اعلاميه بين الامرين طيب دكتور محمد
العادل يتوقف عندما قال اه
وهو يعلن العقوبات على نظام الاسد قال ان
نظام بشار الاسد وصل الى نهايته هل برايك
هذه النبوه
او هذا تنبئ مرتبط ب ثقته
فاعليه هذه العقوبات وقدره بعقوبات على
تحقيق الغايه منها
الامر لم يكن في تقديري متعلقا بالعقوبات
الاخيره التي فرضتها تركيا وانما بقراءه
شامله للموقف داخل سوريا وفي الاطار
الاقليمي والدولي اه تركيا تتابع المساله
السوريه يعني عن كثب يعني
ترى ان امن يعني ما يجري في سوريا سينعكس
بشكل مباشر على تركيا وبالتالي اعتقد بان
ال انقره تدرك تماما بان النهايه بالفعل
نهايه النظام السوري قد قربت اه ليس فقط
من خلال يعني حزمه العقوبات وان كانت هذه
العقوبات ستسفر النظام السوري على امه
تقديم تنازلات او يتجدد شيئا فشيئا يتخلى
عنه
انصاره وتتخلى عنه قياداته سواء كانت
العسكريه او الامنيه او السياسيه
هذا قريبا في تقديري انقره تدرك هذا الامر
هذا من جانب من جانب اخر اعتقد ان لديها
تواصل كبير مع المعارضه السوريه
المعارضه السوريه بدا جانبها يتقوى بدا
لديها حضور دبلوماسي حضور قوي جدا في
الشارع واعتقد ان هذا سينعكس تماما على
فاعليه يعني الثوره السوريه في الداخل
وايضا يعني مدى اشعالها في الخارج كل هذه
الامور تجعل انقره وكل الاطراف واثق بان
نهايه النظام السوري نهايه قريبه وان
النظام السوري لم يعد يعني الان ال
ضيع كل الفرص وحتى مساله الحوار معه لم
تعد الان يعني ممكنه اه اشكر ال جزيل
الشكر الدكتور محمد العادي ال مدير المعهد
التركي العربي للدراسات كنت معنا اذا في
هذا الجزء الاول من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
في الجزء الثاني
سيكون معنا
من القاهره رئيس مؤتمر الانقاذ الوطني
السوري وس نبحث فيه اما اذا ما كان فشل
هذا الخيار وهو خيار العقوبات على سوريا
اه سيؤدي تلقائيا الى خيار التدخل الاجنبي
بعض الفاصل
ام
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى حلقتنا
التي تتناول مدى فعاليه خيار العقوبات
دستوريه وما اذا كان فشل هذا الخيار
يقربنا من تدخل اجنبي اذن كما ذكرت في اه
قبل الفاصل ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف الان من
القاهره يبدو ان ضيفنا ليس جاهزا معنا
الان ان نواصل مع ضيفنا من عمان الدكتور
جواد العناني
دكتور جواد علني بمعرفتك ومعرفه جميع
بخبره النظام السوري في التعامل مع
العقوبات وكان قد نتعايش مع عقوبات
امريكيه سابقه وعقوبات اوروبيه سابقه هل
الايمان بان هذه العقوبات مختلفه القمه
العربيه والتركيه والاوروبيه ايضا يمكن ان
تاتي اكلها وماذا لو فشلت
اه اعتقد بان فشل العقوبات اه ينطوي على
واحد من احتمالين اه اما
ان يبدا ن نعطي اه اه اه ال اه النظام في
سوريا الشعور بانه قد تجاوز مرحله صعبه اه
مما يجعله يشعر بشعور انه انتصر او ان هذا
سيفتح البوابه على مزيد من التصعيد لا
اعتقد بان المعركه الاقتصاديه
سوف تكون قصيره على العكس اعتقد انها
ستكون طويله وان النظام السوري سيتعرض الى
مزيد من الضغوط في المستقبل اه ولا ارى
هنالك وسيله و اجماع عالمي بان اه اه يجب
ايقاف ما يجري الان في سوريا وان على ال
اه النظام السوري ان يدرك بان العالم اه
اه يعني والتعامل معه مختلف كليه عن
التعامل اه اثناء الايام الصيفيه في
الديبلوماسيه العربيه اه الان نحن في وضع
اه اه الناس والعالم كله مصممون وفي ثوره
الربيع العربي على ان ما يجري حاليا في
سوريا اه غير مقبول وان العالم قد اخذ
موقفا من هذا
وان النظام السوري يكون اه اه اه اكثر
انصافا مع نفسه لو ادرك هذه الحقيقه
وتعلم من الدرس
يراه امام عيني في الوقت الحاضر ربما هناك
نقطه مهمه يجب ذكرها وهي ان النظام السوري
له حلفائه ايضا في المنطقه ولا ننسى ايضا
ان لبنان واه ايضا العراق امتنع ان اه لم
يوافق على هذه العقوبات وبالتالي هل تعتقد
ان هناك من حلفاء سوريا من سيذهب الى نجده
النظام واقصد لبنان والعراق
اه اه يعني احنا يمكن ان نستخدم اصطلاح ان
نقول بان هنالك دول الجوار ودول الجوار اه
حوالين سوريا وهو الوضع مختلف على قارناه
مثلا بالوضع ال الذي اه الذي حصل في
العراق حتى عام الفين وثلاثه ووجدنا ان
العراق لم يكن محاطا ب اي جهه كانت مستعده
لان تتعاون معه او تتفهم من هذه الناحيه
النظام السوري يعني يجد في لبنان اه اه
بعض الصديق وفي اه كذلك في العراق ايضا
صديقا اعتقد انه متردد وليس صديقا قويا اه
اه اذا كنا نتحدث عن عمل اقتصادي فاعتقد
انه اذا مورس الضغوط على اه لبنان وعلى
العراق فانها لم يستمر اه في دعم النظام
السوري بالشكل الذي يتوقعه او ان تبقى
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين سوريا وبين
جارتها اه اه على حالها اه ال لان هذه اه
سيكلف هاتين الدولتين اه مبالغ ضخمه جدا
هما غير قادرتين على تقديم ولذلك اه في
رايي انا انه النظام السوري يجب ان يعيد
حساباته بدقه حتى ايران التي تستطيع ان ت
مده بالعملات الاجنبيه اه في الوقت الحاضر
لها قدره محدوده لانها هي نفسها الان
تتعرض الى مزيد من الضغوط والى مزيد من
الحصار الاقتصادي خاصه في ظل ما جرى اه في
السفاره البريطانيه
دعني انتقل انتقل الى غير ان المواطن
كبيره
ضيفه في القاهره يبدو جاهزا الان الاستاذ
هيثم المالح مؤتمر الانقاذ الوطني السوري
اضافه الى ما قاله الدكتور جواد العناني
الان من التحديات تتعلق بدعم الحلفاء
العراق اللبناني وايران ايضا كحليف
استراتيجي بالنسبه لسوريا هناك تحديات
اخرى تتعلق بعدم خبره الدول العربيه
بموضوع العقوبات الدول العربيه ليس لها
الخبره الكافيه في فرض عقوبات ليس هناك
وكالات او هيئات او منظمات التابعه
للجامعه العربيه تؤدي او تقوم بعمليات
الرقابه على فرض هذه العقوبات ربما بسبب
عدم وجود كامل سياسي واقتصادي كامل بين
الدول العربيه الى اي مدى يمكن اذا في ظل
هذه التحديات ان تنجح للعقوبات برايك
تعاقب وكما تعرفون الو
هناك في منتهى الشفافيه
نعم
نعم نعم اسمعك بشكل واضح تفضل
انا اقول يا سيدي اولا الجامعه العربيه
تكون
الوحيد المواقف والمجتمع التوجيه
الهيئات الاقتصاديه التنفيذيه والمصارف
التوجيه
واصحاب النفوذ على مستوى العالم على كل
الاحوال الدول العربيه سوف تضيق الخناق
على هذا النظام الفاسد
انتشر بشكل كامل
لم يعد من مثال
التستر عليها اليوم تعلمون الامارات
طيرانها الى ايران
كل الدول العربيه
الشعب في النظام معزولا
العلم في القريبه
تصعيد العقوبات
بمواجهه الان هذه
وخمسين مليون
النظام كله يرفع خوف من هذه عقوبات يعلم
العقوبات
رساله سياسيه
بعدها سيتم الانتقال الى مرحله التدريب
يرجع
سينتقل الموضوع الى التدريب اذا لم النظام
هذا النظام العام يخرج
عثر على ايه اصر على على يعني مقابلته قبل
الشعب السعودي وانتهاكات حقوق وحرماته
ستنتقل عمليه التسجيل وعندها لا تساعد
النظام ال ان تحاصر
كل شيء ولا
هذه ليست الى حقيقه الرساله ليست فقط في
اقتصادهم هي رساله سياسيه من الجامعه
العربيه
اليوم سعر الصرف
وسينطلق
نفسه
دفع رواتب موظفين لا تفترض مساعده
مساعده العراق في العراق ليس مع النظام
لبنان كلهم النظام استياء فقط تشارك وهناك
معارض في العراق او النظام الحاكم في
العراق ايران لديها المعارضه الداخليه
السياسه الداخليه والخارجيه شكرا اشكرك
جزيل الشكر
هيثم المالح رئيس مؤتمر الانقاذ الوطني
السوري واعتبر للمقاطعه في نهايه وقت
البرنامج اه اشكر ايضا ضيوفنا ضيفنا الذي
كان معنا من عمان ال اه نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاردني الاسبق ورئيس مركز البصره
للدراسات الدكتور جواد العناني شكرا جزيلا
لك على مشاركتك معنا في هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا اطيب
المنى والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ام